[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ابتعاد الزواحف والقوارض عن بطون الاوديه
ومجاري شعاب دليل على قرب قدوم
الوادي ولجوء الطيور الى اوكارها بشكل
مفاجئ دليل على قرب عاصفه عنيفه
وفوضويه حركه النمل ونقلها بيوضها الى
الخارج دليل على قرب حاله مطريه غزيره
وتوقف المياه عن الجريان في غصون الاشجار
دليل على شده البرد فاحساس الحشرات
والنباتات والزواحف والقوارض احساسها
بالمناخ وتقلباته احساس مرهف والعامه
يعتمدون عليها في معرفه الاجواء
المستقبليه كعتمادنا على الاجهزه الحديثه
في الكون كله خلق بتناهم عجيب يستدعي
الانتباه انا كل شيء خلقناه
بقدر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وصفرار وجه السماء واوراق الاشجار دليل
على اعتدال الاجواء بين قوسين الخريف
والعام يسمونه موسم اصفري ليش لانه موسم
انتقالي ومن شان المواسم الانتقاليه ان
الاجواء تكون فيه متقلبه فينتشر الغبار
على وجه السماء فتبدو مصفره وزرقه وجه
السماء وزرقه الاجساد دليل على شده البرد
والعامه يسمونه وموسم الزيرك فخلاله تهب
علينا رياح شماليه تكسح الغبار والهباء
فتبدو السماء مزرقه ناصعه وحمره وجه سماء
وقرص الشمس دليل على اخر مواسم البرد برد
العجوز وبرد بياع الخبل عباته ذكر البرد
زهره الدنيا وجنات نعيم الى دخلنا الشرطه
الحميد
[موسيقى]